The second key concept is the event. Once again it's an abstraction, and
we'll say it's a single, instantaneous, noticeable occurrence. And
also, and also, think of it as some kind of stimulus because the system is going
to respond to it. Events in these kinds of systems can either be asynchronous or
synchronous. Asynchronous events you can think of as kind of randomly occurring,
they can come in bursts, they can be spread out.
Synchronous events are more likely to come at periodic intervals,
often the system has some sort of clock or event loop that controls.
The current events when they can be dealt with in our
approach to modeling these systems the events can
serve as the reason or the stimulus for a change of state in the system.
That, that change of state is sometimes called a state transition. For example,
when you got your envelope through the mail that said you were admitted to
college, that's a significant state transition in your life. Events can
occur as the results of user actions like hitting a, hitting a button on the,
on the graphical user interface. They can occur because of changes in the data,
in the, in the state space the temperature getting above 90 degrees.
Or they can be queued by the passage of time.